they may have swept to victory in the
elections but protesters are back on the
street in Hong Kong once again hundreds
had marched towards the police
checkpoint that leads to the Polytechnic
University where a small group of
protesters remain under siege by the
security services this was a noisy
demonstration but not a particularly
large one
they shouted insults of the officers for
this area is effectively locked down
[Music]
that they were out at all surprised many
people here after their momentous
achievement at the polls there were
already divisions between those who want
peaceful protest and those who actually
believe in more direct action which
usually leads to violence those
divisions I'm sure are going to grow
because after the election results son
believe they should have no more street
protests but an awful lot believe they
should maintain their presence on the
streets even if it leads to
confrontation some of the victorious
brand-new councillors gathered in a park
close to the University complex
delegation was allowed to enter the
university most seemed a little stunned
by the fact that so many from their
ranks had actually won their unofficial
leaders are jubilant there's no reason
for Beijing ignore the more than two
minutes people wards in an election
especially most of this in already wrong
by our camp
while the direction of the opposition
movement has been debated most people I
spoke to say they need to keep pushing
keep going under this tree so this is
like the beginning yeah if the only end
already the beginning yeah for most of
their Hong corners we will go on for our
protests and then fight for freedom or
fight more
- to tell the government they have to do
something to us through the night they
celebrated a seat after seat fell to the
pro-democracy party when even as the
count took place it was clear the huge
voter turnout had supported the protest
movement while a movement has been
reinvigorated by such strong support
after six long months of protest and
violence nothing has actually changed
the Hong Kong government is still in
charge in Beijing has warned that
violence must stop the fact is neither
side is listening to the other mr.
Ramsay Sky News Hong Kong